[Music]
Matthew is with us in Tucson Arizona st.
Matthew welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call appreciate
it sure what's up so I have a question
about buying a house okay I am I'm
currently in debt we are working our
snowballs and our snowball and we are
living in an apartment and we're paying
about nine hundred and fifty dollars in
rent
now you would tell me do not go into
debt buy a house and that's really good
advice on that and I will agree with
that my question is what does the number
doesn't change what does picking a house
and I'm renting or and my mortgage is
940 and I'm still working the snowball
then the math doesn't change oh you're
saying I would say don't buy a house
until you're out of debt and have our
emergency fund in place and then a down
payment well the reason is pretty simple
housing is never as simple as your lyall
as you're laying it out if the not
because the number does change it's more
expensive to home home than it is to
rent on a monthly cash flow basis
because that 950 dollar payment also
represents a hot water heater that goes
out or heating in their system that has
to be updated or a roof that leaks and
and grass that has to be cut and so on
there's always costs associated with
operating a home it's worth it home
ownership is worth it because it goes up
in value and because you stabilize your
monthly payment it's worth it in the
long haul so all right you know I love
that day you owning a home because you
you know your rents going to go up over
a 10 or 15 year period you're going to
come out a lot better owning a home but
over a ten-month period you're not which
is how you're analyzing it which is just
your monthly rent versus your monthly
house payment and it's get into a home
to rent but those are the rents in
Tucson are you know twelve hundred or
not yeah well how much debt have you got
32,000 okay what's your household income
I believe this last year we cleared I
think it was either 52 or 53 together
anymore I'm not I'm going to totally
short that's okay
so how long do you don't take to pay off
thirty two then
we've hit a lot of snags we wanted to
have it paid off in two years we short
story we're renting a home and decided
we were going to save the money on that
rent and moved in with my parents and
their small two-bedroom home with three
kids and you know my life and that
didn't really work out so it kind of
pushed behind and you know through other
years basically so why did that put you
behind I understand that it didn't work
out but why that didn't work out because
all the money that we we had to use that
we were trying to save or not saved but
put towards yet had to be used to get
into a nut back into another apartment
and then get back as far as murder if
you fall off then tossed you fifteen
thousand dollars to do that in two years
why no we just we just lost you to class
with our parents like we we had just
barely got out of it so it was a really
bad move to try to do that but the point
is you're exaggerating okay
you didn't you know if you make $50,000
a year even with a bat even with moving
twice you should be able to pay off
thirty two thousand dollars in two years
no you know that the the move did not
cost you fifteen thousand dollars a year
for two years it just didn't cost you
that there's that's impossible right so
it kind of might cost you make it cost
you a lot of hassle and it cost you to
not concentrate not focus and not stay
on your budget I think honestly if you
wanted the answer that day it just cost
us to kind of get off and to kind of
well forget it that makes it and that's
actually logical I can't blame you for
that I've done that kind of thing myself
so yeah but what I would do is say let's
start today look forward and say okay
fifty plus it plus whatever income we
can pick up doing other things and we're
going to just bear down and say boom how
fast can we pay off thirty-two making
fifty well if you paid off fifteen a
year you'd be a sixteen year you'll be
done in two years and you can you can do
that that's very very very doable as a
matter of fact I think you're probably
going to do it in eighteen months
because I think you're really gonna be
sick of that apartment you're gonna be
on beans and rice rice and beans
we're gonna focus completely focus we're
gonna lean into this we're not going to
get distracted ever again it's
completely blinders we're looking only
at the goal don't care what anybody
thinks not going to
Gus this with anybody we're just gonna
do it and when you lean in like that
with that complete focus you can do that
have you guys been through Financial
Peace University yeah we went through
with our church like I said that was
what three years ago now go back through
okay
and let that but that as a matter of
fact let me sign you up again because
it's on a membership basis now and
that'll get you into the every dollar
Plus and give you the online access and
plug in again because what you've got to
do you need to get the the the peer
pressure around you that's positive the
other people that are on the path
that'll hold you accountable and say
stick with it dude stay on stay on stay
on the road don't get in the ditch stay
on the road don't get in the ditch and
yeah go back get join another group I'll
pay for it you you can go back to and
I'll get you signed up for all the
online for a year and the every dollar
plus for a year and then join a group in
the area again and cuz that's what you
you've just you've gotten distracted and
I'm trying more than I'm trying to get
your focus back and I want your focus to
be laser extreme and then you're gonna
get your house you can get your house
but don't let the house get you if you
had owned a house with what you've been
through in the last two years you might
have gotten foreclosed on you you could
have been in a real mess here cuz your
budgets tight you mean you got kids
running around you got debt that you got
debt tonight yours
you got a tight budget and the house
represents risk in that situation that's
why we always say Murphy moving your
spare bedroom and bring his three
cousins broke desperate and stupid with
him so hold on I'll have Kelly pick up
we'll get you reassigned and get you in
the Financial Peace University
membership for a year